the u.n estimates more than 666 thousand
people have fled the country because of
the fighting long lives have formed at
ukrainian's western border as women and
children leave family members behind to
join the fight many refugees arrived
exhausted with no place to go chris
livesay is along the border
it's an exodus that shows no signs of
slowing at ukraine's border with poland
refugees line up for more than 20 miles
in freezing temperatures yearning for
safety
at the beaves main train station in
western ukraine thousands more try
desperately to get out
but not everyone can
the war isn't just driving families away
it's driving families apart women and
children are fleeing the country while
men of fighting age are running into
battle
so you left your father in ukraine to
fight
yes yes
i like i love my country
this russia is bad country
men some difficult not to call boys now
face frontline combat even though
they've never held a gun like 18 year
old medical student yaroslav if i must
no i i will go
did you ever imagine you'd be faced with
something like this no i
i
it's like a nightmare
what were you doing a week ago
i just texted with my girlfriend i just
going
with my friends and i sitting at
computer and i
don't imagine that
russia invaded in my country
so
and just like that things changed yes
yes just
like boom and
okay sorry
yaroslav was with his six-year-old
sister michelle they had just said
goodbye to their father who like so many
ukrainians was staying back to fight
this war robbing ukraine not just of
human life but of its innocence and so
much of its youth as well tony
yeah and then of course they wait for
word if they make it out of the country
are there are their brothers and their
fathers okay their sons chris loves say
in western ukraine chris thank you very
much